[Musique]
rochefort sur mer
une place qui a l'air tranquille
et pourtant les maisons ont des couleurs
pastel elle volé son jaune vert violet
ou framboises
jacques demy en effet il tourne les
demoiselles de rochefort sur une musique
de son inséparable ami michel legrand à
qui l'on doit également celle des
parapluies de cherbourg vedette de cette
nouvelle comédie musicale jean kelly
george chakiris le héros de west side
story
danielle darrieux michel piccoli jacques
perrin et françoise dorléac et catherine
donald soeur dans la vie françoise et
catherine deviennent jumelles dans ce
film
l'une est professeur de solfège l'autre
professeur de danse
jacques demy pourquoi rochefort c'est
vrai tout à fait par hasard
oui d'abord la découverte de la vie
comme ça j'ai vu beaucoup de villes dont
je suis pas en tout cas la côte
méditerranéenne
j'ai fait de nice à perpignan effet une
très grande place très architecturé com
com et rochefort
justement j'ai trouvé rochefort après je
suis retourné sur la côte d'azur et
finalement je suis revenu au front au
moment des parapluies de cherbourg de
jacques demy vous vouliez définir votre
film comme un film jazz que l'on peut
dire la même chose pour moi
rochefort oui mais alors contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait penser à pas c'est une
comédie musicale mais je ne fais pas sur
la musique je fais sur leur sentiment
sur l'assentiment de la vie sur un
sentiment de joie donc décidé de capter
cette espèce du bonheur donc ça d'être
dit son sein vivent en ville comme ça on
vous le sentez joyeux et communiquer
cette espèce de joie les la rend plus
urgent est la danse qui permet
classement l'explosion de
j'adhère je suis pas me semble que là
c'est intéressant sur ce plan là vous
entendez bien d'accord mondial à son
habitude de vivre ensemble dans les
petits 17 ans 118 ensemble mais je crois
que c'est à françois nom catherine que
vous devez d'avoir fait du cinéma
oui c'est exact et quelqu'un ne m'en
veut bien raconté shelly eh bien je
tournais je devais tourner les portes
claquent et dans le film j'ai vu van
ninh soeur et le producteur franz von
m'a demandé si on cassait pas quelqu'un
qui me ressemblait beaucoup à j-6 une
somme dont line vous connu enfin non pas
assez et c'est comme ça que catherine a
commenté ainsi les mains et elle n'est
pas 50 ans d'ailleurs elle a fait parce
que c'était les vacances des grandes
vacances à sommières poussé c'est de
pousser dans le tea party elle tout
peine digérée savent ça vous manque pas
par exemple n'avoir pas fait comme
françoise de conservatoire nous sommes
deux
[Musique]
désigner des gémeaux l'ifac cela n'irait
ré mi fa sol sonnerait donc soutenu d'un
mois zèle ayant eu des enfants très tôt
il fasse cela m'irait ré mi fa sol
rideau
françoise dorléac et catherine deneuve
censeurs dans la vie elles sont jumelles
dans le film que tourne jacques demy qui
s'appelle les demoiselles de rochefort
bon on peut prins en place
allons-y moteur les bacs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'habit chanter leur sommeil aux
déplaces santé le jour chanter la nuit
dans certaines villes mais son moteur
les bacs
[Musique]
sans l'étayer a disparu les luttes en le
pensant et à les étaler du côté des
saisons monde
on ne peut que soupirer
mais pour un délire un jour d'été
lorsque l'hiver s'est installé
et que votre cas c'est glacé il faut
aimer
jacques demy les demoiselles ou un
caractère évidemment très différent
solange un caractère moderne ya qu au
fond d'elle-même dans ce qu'elle soit
très romantique et delphine qui n
apparaissent romantique ça et finalement
plus modernes suivant leur caractère et
suivant la révolution
elles ont de toute façon le même
problème toutes les deux sont à la
recherche de l'amour
nous sommes déçus mais pas seulement
rémy passage ça sonnerait donc tout
ayant fait les alentours une fois sa
taille
toledo nous émeut tout nommé ne vais pas
maman danielle darrieux ses prix bas
travail à paris yann
elle roulait de re2 érudit
et pour cela vendre
de sa vie des frises françoise rêve de
jouer la dame aux camélias et catherine
rôles comme arriver salonsce des
françoises et delphine cd4 et
bathymétriques merci la reine
oui un petit que je me fasse la vente a
vu ce que je me permets catherine
deneuve fabrice abriel rencontre tombe
dans les cimes françoise dorléac luc
savard finale et que je vois quand même
et qu il m avait dit je me sers conseil
roche
non mais je crois qu'ils allaient voyez
maintenant je m en 10 ans par exemple
en tous les cas d'un seul coup tu as une
protestante en visant jean marc simon
drac du fermage l'agencé plus petit café
madsen tranquillement kg de moules pour
tous
vous avez maintenant ils sont tous fans
allemands il a fait de drôles bon c'est
pas vrai en langage c'est sûr que vous
visez droit
oui oui c'est l'itinéraire
non c'est une erreur du petit miroir dis
moi si j'ai vraiment la plus laide lui
c'était ça venait est comme ça une
espèce d'instinct de jeu d'enfant
[Musique]
la rochelle à new york en midi où va ma
route qu'elle soit timide et très
complexée qu'elle ne se connaissent pas
du tout ne s'achète pas comment
s'habiller qu'elle sache jamais comment
se tenir
c'est pas pour faire de ses bras tout ça
c'est vrai mais elle est tellement
comédienne elle aime tellement joué que
finalement elle va passer par dessus sa
timidité par deux suspects comme ça
starter pour votre partage abîmes du
manger à sec
on rejoindra pas tournage mais tu nous
as bon j'adore jouer les gros plan
aujourd'hui
ok chéri
peut-être bien sympathique de
l'allemagne est une chose qui est très
quelques très belles c'est qu'elle sait
d'ores et déjà nés ou dîné avec elle ça
régale
c'était un festival de basri gentil
lequel se lance comme ça mais tu es bon
juan trahis depuis sûrement dès
l'enfance
laquelle est la doublure de l'os
ma soeur a tapoté il donc de plus en
plus qu'est-ce qu'ils se parlent
ne restent pas moi je me risque pas
d'arriver au baseball en france où les
eagles alors vielmon lève les bras au
smic pour l'embrasser devant le mauvais
sillage il vous faut aller allons-y
allons-y pour le faire ça il est bien au
point est très bien car de catherine
bon après on peut quatre moteurs
rocheman pendant cinq buts s'enchaînent
les bacs au sourire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et là me chantait cet amoureux des
fleurs chanter le jour où santé la nuit
schaper fallait
armand jean denis lejeune santé la mer
feront feu sans permis
[Musique]
j'entrerai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est bien
le sang
c'est à rochefort que nous avons
retrouvé jacques demy et son équipe
après les parapluies de cherbourg mag
bodard productrice jacques demy
réalisateur michel le grand compositeur
se sont retrouvés afin de réaliser la
première comédie musicale française et
demoiselles de rochefort
ces demoiselles se sont françoise
dorléac et catherine deneuve ayant
respectivement comme partenaire jean
caby et jacques perrin cette
distribution est complétée par danielle
darrieux michel piccoli est george
chakiris que nous avions découvert dans
west side story
là
e
non
oui
[Musique]
moi
rabat
[Musique]
ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]
à
parlant de monde
m
[Musique]
j'aurais aimé non
dollars
parmi eux andré
le
[Musique]
jg
il a cette bouderie des hommes
j'ai dit à marie
de salinité nenê
vie démocratique et du poète en à la vie
illimitée
je pourrais parler de ces vieux le ses
mains je pourrais tu parler de lui
jusqu'à demain
non
c'est ma vie et je voulais
une vision de l'amour ce n'est pas
l'amour trouver
sait-il pas et humain
et tymoschuk en jeu
au contraire car je sais qu'il existe
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la raison aucun
le plus fort à son ordre à sa loi
personne ne résiste
je n'y résistera
pas
je le cherchais partout j'ai fait le
tour du monde
de venise un g20 de manille encore
de jeannette victoria devenu saint
jacques on
je ne les ai pas trouvés et je la
cherche encore
je ne connais rien
et pourtant je la vois
j'ai inventé son os j'ai entendu sa voix
j'ai dû signer son corps et j'ai peur
son visage son portrait l'amour ne
feront plus qu'une image
elle a cette beauté des filles
romantiques et d'un botticelli regard
innocent
sans profil est celui de ces vieilles je
me dis qu'ils hantent les musées
l'esa
sa démarche ressemble aux souvenirs
d'enfant qui trotte dans ma tête et dans
cet enlèvement
sur son français cher
100 $ en bataille que
vent de la mer et le soleil
jama
je pourrais vous parler de ses yeux de
ses mains
je pourrais vous parler d'elle
jusqu'à demain
son amant c'est ma vie mais à quoi bon
rêver je les cherchait partout je ne les
ai pas trouvés
jacques perrin pourrait peut-être oui je
rappelle qu'elle est n quel titre il n'y
a pas un titre c'est pas une chanson
vous répéter pour les demoiselles de
rochefort
oui le tournage du film votre playback
et bien écoutez satisfait ses pairs
cette chanson est la chanson clés du
personnage de max en ce que je fais et
c'est une chanson où ils cherchent ils
évoquent la femme idéale la famille dit
qu'il a toujours recherché et auquel
pourtant lui prêtent déjà des yeux
défini de nouveaux jeux très précise
enfin déjà il a complètement dessiné en
lui et il cherche à travers le monde a
rencontré ce visage qu'il s'est déjà
créé et d'ailleurs et le pire est
artiste peintre et il a peint le visage
de cette fille est cette fille ressemble
étonnamment à une jeune fille à une des
deux soeurs des demoiselles de rochefort
qui est catherine deneuve glenn close
est ce que c'est beaucoup de moi je
crois parce que quand jacques assez que
françoise et moi nous allions faire
nocives
hilali beaucoup de nous mêmes dans les
personnages c'est important je veux dire
sans changer son histoire je crois c'est
très important dans nos colonnes
comédienne est conté dont la personne'
et décide de le remettre des choses de
ta propre personnalité
pour les aider et ensuite pour avant
qu'un ex punta nelly tes dents dans
certaines scènes jamais plus ça va
beaucoup aider et des choses que je
trouve qu'ils sont un petit peu moi je
crois que c'est pareil pour françoise de
colas beaucoup de complicité quand on
faisait des ensembles plus facile de
rire avec elles viennent prenez bien
[Musique]
testez pas la cellule et soyez chic nous
ne voulons pas vous être antipathique ne
nous fait pas à vous cogner dessus à
bras raccourcis
j'avais du sang jusqu'ici c'était une
petite vieille au blanc cheveux
c'est propre m'envient monde je n'aime
que les blondes c'est très gentil pour
moi monsieur
ne vous fâchez pas je n'aime que les
blonds mais ce n'est pas parce que vous
êtes risque avec un couteau
je vous ferai en morceaux pourquoi
seriez-vous c'est ignoble sadique ma foi
non et vous j'enseigne la musique parce
que ça me plaît moi je fais de la
peinture abstraite mais j'ai une
ambition concrètes
je cherche vainement mon idéal
alors je les peins chez moi venez le
voir une fois nous ferons connaissance a
créé maxence le jour vous avez su vous
alliez faire la comédie musicale de
jacques demy que vous alliez être la
partenaire de jean pays à ce moment là
que j'ai eu peur affreusement peur et
puis ensuite je me suis maintenant j'ai
travaillé dix fois plus la première fois
que j'ai commencé à travailler ni kelly
et et que j'ai commencé à en faire
répéter avec lui c'était abominable ce
que je tremblais j'étais complètement
paniqué il lui a commencé à s'ouvrir et
vous inquiétez pas ça va être tout
évêque très facile puis comme ça dans 7
mois people kounta pneus de grandes
sommes dit pourquoi vous ai commencé de
ce pied là alors je n'ai pas encore pu
paniquer pile il s'est mis à rire et
puis tout était très détendue tout de
suite mais la première fois je laisse eu
impact du monde m'a dit tu sais ton
partenaire va janis kelly
j'étais complètement affolée mais
attends je suis très heureuse d'avoir
très heureux aujourd'hui j'ai une qualif
vous êtes acteur acteurs chorégraphe
metteur en scène hollywood vous a
consacré aujourd'hui vous êtes un dit
miller dans la comédie musicale de
jacques demy les demoiselles de
rochefort
une comédie musicale réalisée en france
loin des studios de hollywood
ce n'est pas la première fois que vous
tournez en france vous étonner en france
avant gg tous les deux trois points en
france mais c'est la première fois que
j'ai essayé de tourner en français
beaucoup de déférence pour sa grande
aventure
j'aime beaucoup mon accent et c'est
terrible mais c'est amusant et la
chorégraphie squire régime je sais très
bien fait de crayon gras cru et c'est no
mad men et c'est un jeune en grès
d'aller bonne idée
j'ai fait les gabelous très moderne et
hop très compromise mais avec un 10 ans
comme ça moi j'aime beaucoup
vous avez travaillé avec nous mêmes et
mènera encore cgg travées seulement 8
michel lacombe avant plusieurs fois mais
c'est la première fois avec norman
première fois rakhshan très content très
content très content qu ici il faut
mange bien
nous sommes deux soeurs ni face à
l'avenir est réuni ce passage sonnerait
dont toutes ne donne
elles ayant utilisé un vin très tôt il
fasse cela m'irait lemmy face au seul
raid au nouveau sur toutes deux mais le
départ mamans qui font ce prix bas
travail à bayamon
elle voulait de nous faire des érudits
et pour cela vendre toute sa vie des
frites
non ça veut tout denis le père inconnu
cela ne se voit pas mais quand nous
sommes venus nous avons tout de l'autre
des reins c'est fou là un drain de voter
qu'ils avaient sur la joue nous sommes
deux soeurs jumelles nées sous le signe
des gémeaux me fasse à l'avenir et rémy
façonne salle rideaux et non une
ritournelle les calembours et les bons
mots bis face à la ville et rémy fatah
seule salle rideau
pour ces deux demoiselles catherine et
françoise dorléac le tout paris hier
soir avait les yeux de jacques demy car
après les parapluies de cherbourg
il vient de réaliser avec michel legrand
les demoiselles de rochefort
jacques demy vous devenez un spécialiste
de la comédie musicale parce que j'aime
bien ce qui sort des sentiers battus
revel excentive sont intéressants ce qui
est tout à fait fascinant c'est la cd
chercher quelque chose de nouveau
je crois au sein des attaches dans la
création précisément de faire des choses
différentes et par exemple le film que
j'avais fait précédemment était un film
plus tôt
grave sérieux et j'avais envie de
trouver un sentiment de joie comme ça
qui fait que le spectateur trouve un
encouragement une une détente à sourire
et voilà en face au début du film on
peut dire que c'est la première comédie
musicale française
je ne sais pas fayolle des tentatives
quand même se fait vraiment le média
très longtemps et enfin vous il y alors
ça vous n'avez pas fait de comédie
musicale en france
est ce que vous comptez poursuivre avec
avec notre ami michel legrand dans cette
voie je ne sais pas je ne peux pas vous
dire pour l'instant parce que c'est un
tel travail j'ai été longtemps sur ce
sur ce film maintenant je suis
vide et sans idées et sans jugement sur
tout et j'ai besoin de faire le point et
puis de réfléchir et puis je sais qu'une
petite mécanique se mettra en route et
que automatiquement je te revois ce que
j'ai à faire
alors ce sera peut-être un autre musical
effectivement catherine deneuve le matin
comme ça après le triomphal le succès du
film hier soir qu'est ce qui se passe ce
que vous ressentez je veux c'est un
petit peu là pour vous avez fêté le
succès oui d'abord parce que le film a
commencé assez tard et quand il y avait
[Musique]
chez moi que vous ne parliez de jacques
demy cas vous êtes l'enfant chéri de
jacques demy on peut lui dire ça et moi
vous puisque c'est mon intervention
chéri par forcené dont j'aimerais que
vous me parlez de nuit comme c'est
quelqu'un de très tendre très de très
doux et très violent à la fois de très
sûr de lui
c'est très ambitieux c'est quelqu'un qui
vient qui est maître au bord de la mer
qui vous ont eu vent de la mer pour
vivre je crois d'ailleurs il a une
maison alain gautier souvent et qui a
besoin du bandana vous travaillez aussi
c'est pour ça qu'il fait toujours des
films dans l'effort
[Musique]